There's this scene in a book I love, About a Boy , by Nick Hornby. The situation in the scene is this. There's this very well-meaning guy who's decided that a good way to meet women would be to join a group for single parents. He's not a single parent himself. He has no children at all. But this guy, whose name is Will, goes to a meeting and gets caught up in conversations. He finds himself making up all sorts of things about his non-existent child and non-existent ex-wife.
我喜爱的一本书里有这样一个场景，尼克·霍恩比（Nick Hornby）写的《单亲插班生》（About a Boy）。场景里的情况是这样的：一个心地非常善良的男人，认为结识女性的一个好办法就是加入一个单亲家长互助组。但他自己并不是单亲家长，他根本没有孩子。不过，这个名叫威尔（Will）的男人还是去参加了会议，并卷入了谈话。他发现自己开始编造各种关于他并不存在的孩子和并不存在的前妻的事情。
There's a tall, blond woman named Susie at the meeting. She's nervy-looking. She's beautiful. They chat. They make plans to meet at a picnic for kids and parents. And, comes the day of, Will calls Susie to tell her that his son, Ned, will not be there. Now, Ned will not be there because Ned does not exist, but Will tells Susie that Ned won't be there because his mom has taken him for the day, at the last minute. Susie tells Will that Will needs to stand up to his non-existent ex-wife a little more firmly. And then there's this passage, which I'm going to read.
会议上有一位高个子的金发女性，名叫苏西（Susie）。她看起来有些紧张，但很漂亮。他们聊了起来，并商定在一次儿童与家长的野餐会上见面。到了那天，威尔给苏西打电话，告诉她他的儿子内德（Ned）不会去了。其实内德不会去是因为内德根本不存在，但威尔告诉苏西，是因为内德的妈妈临时把孩子接走了。苏西告诉威尔，他对那个不存在的前妻应该更强硬一点。接着，就是我要读的这一段。
It was much more confusing than Will had imagined, making people up, and he was beginning to realize that he hadn't thought it through properly at all. How could he carry it through? How many times could Ned reasonably be whisked away by his mother, or maternal grandmother, or international terrorists? What reasons could he give for not inviting Susie round to his flat where there were no toys, or cribs, or diapers, or balls, and where there was no second bedroom even? Could he kill Ned off with some awful disease? A car crash? Tragic. Tragic. Life goes on. Maybe not. Parents got pretty cut up about kids dying, and he'd find the requisite years of grief a real drain on his thespian resources. No, disaster was approaching, and there was nothing he can do about it. Best pull out now. Walk away. But walking away wasn't Will's style. He always felt something would turn up, even though nothing ever did, or even could most the time.
编造谎言比威尔想象的要复杂得多，他开始意识到自己根本没考虑周全。他该怎么把这个谎圆下去？内德的母亲，或者外祖母，甚至国际恐怖分子，可以把内德带走多少次？他能给出什么理由不邀请苏西到他的公寓去呢？那里没有玩具、婴儿床、尿布或球，甚至连第二间卧室都没有。他能让内德死于某种可怕的疾病吗？车祸？太悲剧了。太悲剧了。生活还要继续。也许不行。父母对孩子的死亡会非常痛苦，而他觉得去应付几年必需的悲伤，对他那点表演功底来说简直是巨大的消耗。不，灾难即将降临，他束手无策。最好现在就退出，走人。但走人不是威尔的风格。他总是觉得会有转机，尽管大多数时候根本没有什么转机，也不可能有什么转机。
Once, years ago, when he was a kid, he told a school friend, having first ascertained that this friend was not a CS Lewis fan, that it was possible to walk through the back of his wardrobe into a different world, and invited him around to explore. He could have canceled. He could have told him anything. But he was not prepared to suffer a moment's mild embarrassment if there was no immediate need to do so.
很久以前，还是个孩子的时候，有一次他告诉一个校友——在确认对方不是C·S·路易斯的粉丝后——说穿过他衣柜的背面就能进入另一个世界，还邀请对方去探险。他本可以取消的，他本可以找任何借口。但他不想在没有迫切需要的情况下，去承受哪怕一丁点儿轻微的尴尬。
And so the two of them scrabbled around among the coat hangers for several minutes until Will mumbled something about the world being closed on Saturday afternoons. The thing was, he could still remember feeling genuinely hopeful right up to the last minute. Maybe there will be something here, he had thought. Maybe I won't lose face. There wasn't, and he did, loads of it, a whole head full of face. But he hadn't learned a thing from the experience. If anything, it seemed to have left him with the feeling that he was bound to be lucky next time.
于是，他们俩在衣架之间翻找了几分钟，直到威尔嘟囔着说那个世界周六下午关门。关键是，直到最后一刻，他依然能感觉到自己是真心怀着希望的。他当时想，也许那里真的会有什么东西。也许我就不用丢脸了。结果什么都没有，他也丢尽了脸，丢得彻彻底底。但他从这次经历中一点教训也没学到。如果说有什么改变的话，那就是这次经历反而让他觉得，下次他一定会走运。
As this scene makes clear, there are different kinds of deception. And the line between deceiving others and deceiving yourself can get kind of hazy, especially when hope comes into play. Today on our program, the three kinds of deception-- at least we're claiming that there are only three for the purposes of this radio show-- the three kinds of deception and how any one of them so easily turns into any one of the others.
正如这个场景所展示的，欺骗有多种形式。欺骗他人与欺骗自己之间的界限可能会变得相当模糊，尤其是在涉及希望的时候。今天在我们的节目中，我们将讨论三种欺骗——至少为了这期广播节目，我们声称只有这三种——这三种欺骗以及它们中的任何一种是如何轻易转化为另一种的。
Act One of our program, Self-Deception, the story of an ex-con who not only told himself a lot of things that were untrue, he created a sort of web of unreality around himself so that dozens of people in a small town started kidding themselves about what was real and what was not real. And then, all of them together, decided to make a feature film.
节目的第一幕，自欺欺人，讲述了一个前罪犯的故事，他不仅对自己说了许多不实之词，还在自己周围编织了一张虚假的网，让一个小镇上的几十个人开始自欺欺人，分不清现实与虚幻。然后，他们所有人竟然决定一起拍摄一部故事片。
Act Two, Deceiving Others, an African-American lawyer in a fancy Manhattan firm decides that he wants to see what life is like in the exclusive country clubs that his colleagues go to. So he enters one the only way that they would let a black man like him in.
第二幕，欺骗他人，一位在曼哈顿一家高级律师事务所工作的非裔美国律师，决定去看看他的同事们经常出入的高级乡村俱乐部到底是什么样子的。于是，他用唯一一种能让像他这样的黑人进入的方式混了进去。
Act Three, Accidental Deception, American tourists in Paris accidentally mistake writer David Sedaris for a French pickpocket. At first it makes him mad, and then he starts to kind of like it. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
第三幕，意外的欺骗，美国游客在巴黎意外地把作家大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）误当作法国扒手。起初他很生气，但后来他居然开始喜欢这种感觉了。这里是来自WBEZ芝加哥和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Self-Deception. It's a truism that a great salesman has to actually believe the lies he tells to make the sale, the way a great actor has to believe in his own part. This next story is about somebody who aspires to be a great actor, but, in fact, is probably just a great salesman, a charmer in the old school. Alex Blumberg has the story of how he convinced an entire town a bunch of things that, on deeper examination, were more hope than truth.
第一幕，自欺欺人。一个公认的事实是，优秀的推销员必须真正相信自己推销的谎言才能完成交易，就像优秀的演员必须相信自己的角色一样。接下来的这个故事是关于一个渴望成为伟大演员的人，但事实上，他可能只是一个伟大的推销员，一个老派的魅力男。亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）将讲述他如何让整个小镇相信了一堆事情，而这些事情在深入考察后发现，比起事实，更多的是一种愿望。
Of all the tall tales Richard Castellano told, the most incredible one was the easiest to actually verify. He had been in a film with Robert De Niro and Billy Crystal called Analyze This. He had a total of 16 lines. Almost all of them were one or two sentences long. He sounded like this.
在理查德·卡斯特拉诺（Richard Castellano）讲述的所有荒诞故事中，最不可思议的一个其实是最容易核实的。他曾参演过罗伯特·德尼罗（Robert De Niro）和比利·克里斯托（Billy Crystal）主演的电影《老大靠边闪》（Analyze This）。他一共只有16句台词，几乎每句都只有一两句话长。他听起来是这样的。
What are you, some kind of moron?
你是什么人，白痴吗？
This is the story of the power that 16 little lines like that can have, how those 16 lines can be parlayed into money, and excitement, and hope for lots of people. And it starts shortly after Richard Castellano finished filming Analyze This and moved with his wife to a tiny community in upstate New York where there's one main street, called Main Street, one block long, and one bridge across the Delaware River to Pennsylvania. It's called Narrowsburg and, with a population in the hundreds, it's, literally, a hamlet.
这就是那16句小台词所拥有的力量的故事，这些台词是如何被用来换取金钱、兴奋和许多人的希望的。这一切始于理查德·卡斯特拉诺拍完《老大靠边闪》之后，带着妻子搬到了纽约州北部的一个小社区。那里只有一条主街，就叫主街（Main Street），全长只有一个街区，还有一座横跨特拉华河通往宾夕法尼亚州的桥。这个地方叫纳罗斯堡（Narrowsburg），人口只有几百人，名副其实是一个小村庄。
There's no population requirement to be a hamlet. If it were bigger than that, it would be a village, and we don't have a village because it's not enough people.
成为村庄对人口没有要求。如果比这大一点，它就会成为一个镇，但我们没有成为镇，因为人还不够多。
Dick Crandall is the supervisor of Narrowsburg. Supervisor's what you call a mayor when a town's too small to have mayors. And he remembers when Castellano-- Richie, as he came to be called-- first moved to town. In fact, everyone here has a story.
迪克·克兰德尔（Dick Crandall）是纳罗斯堡的督察。督察就是当城镇太小没有市长时对负责人的称呼。他还记得卡斯特拉诺——后来大家叫他里奇（Richie）——刚搬到镇上时的情形。事实上，这里的每个人都有一个关于他的故事。
He was a kind of a flamboyant personality, absolutely. He wore his dark clothes from New York City and a leather jacket open. And he swashbuckled down the street a little bit, and hollered, and talked to everybody, and, you know, was sort of a conquering hero-type person.
他绝对是个张扬的人物。他穿着从纽约市带来的深色衣服，敞开着皮夹克。他在街上走起路来有些大摇大摆，大声叫喊，和每个人说话，你知道，就像是一个凯旋归来的英雄。
He was larger than life, he absolutely was. He would walk into what was then the Chatterbox Cafe and say that he was buying everybody's breakfast. And he would walk in and say, "Hi. I'm Richard Castellano, and I'm buying breakfast." And then he would walk out.
他确实是那种比生活更夸张的人。他会走进当时的“聊天室咖啡馆”（Chatterbox Cafe），说他要请所有人吃早餐。他会走进去说：“嘿，我是理查德·卡斯特拉诺，我请大家吃早餐。”然后他就走掉了。
And he liked to sign stuff, and every time I see him he gives me signed stuff of himself, pictures of himself and a bunch of stuff. He signs everything. The first time I went to his office, he had me run over to the restaurant to get him a cup of coffee. And he wrote down what he wanted in the coffee, and he signed that.
他喜欢给人签名，每次我见到他，他都会给我一些他自己的签名纪念品，他的照片和一堆东西。他什么都签。第一次我去他的办公室时，他让我跑去餐厅给他买杯咖啡。他写下了他想喝的咖啡的要求，然后连那个也签了名。
He started talking about his checkered background. He didn't hide it. People really liked that story, you know, of a guy who was a con, and look at him now, and he's in a movie with De Niro, you know?
他开始谈论他那坎坷的背景。他并不掩饰。人们真的很喜欢那个故事，你知道，一个曾经是罪犯的人，看看他现在，他正在和德尼罗一起拍电影，你懂吗？
He told people that the name of Narrowsburg was going to be changed to Castellanoville.
他告诉人们，纳罗斯堡的名字要改成“卡斯特拉诺维尔”（Castellanoville）。
He said he heisted a armored car, and he got sent up to Attica. He said to me-- he said it to many people-- that he had $2 million stashed away.
他说他抢劫了一辆装甲车，然后被送进了阿提卡（Attica）监狱。他对我说——他也对很多人说过——他存了200万美元。
From his bank heist?
从银行抢劫里得来的？
Yeah. I mean, he told me he killed somebody.
对。我是说，他还告诉我他杀过人。
That was about the extent of my impression of him, except he called me Bill, which didn't make me too happy because my name is Dick.
我对他的印象基本就是这样了，除了他管我叫比尔（Bill），这让我很不高兴，因为我叫迪克（Dick）。
It isn't easy to get an interview with Richard Castellano. My first instructions were to call, let it ring once, hang up, and call back again so they knew it was me. When we finally do meet, it's in Manhattan in his lawyer's office with his lawyer there.
想要采访理查德·卡斯特拉诺可不容易。我的第一条指令是打电话，响一声挂断，然后再打一次，这样他们就知道是我了。当我们最终见面时，是在曼哈顿他律师的办公室里，他的律师也在场。
Castellano's in his 50s, but good-looking in that Hollywood way-- slim, well-dressed in expensive blacks and grays, good haircut. He says he understands why everyone in Narrowsburg was so excited to meet him.
卡斯特拉诺50多岁，但长着一张好莱坞式的帅脸——身材苗条，穿着昂贵的黑色和灰色衣服，发型整洁。他说他理解为什么纳罗斯堡的每个人见到他都那么兴奋。
You know, I've met celebrities myself and I still get that-- what's that word-- I was smitten by people I met in movie theaters. And I remember, when I was a kid, I saw the Three Stooges. They made a personal appearance at the Avon Theater here in Brooklyn. I shook their hands.
你知道，我自己也见过名人，那种感觉我依然……怎么说呢，我在电影院遇见的人让我非常着迷。我记得小时候看过“三个臭皮匠”（Three Stooges）。他们在布鲁克林的雅芳剧院（Avon Theater）现场露面过。我和他们握了手。
How did you feel when you met them?
你见到他们时是什么感觉？
I'm still talking about it. There must have been some effect, right? So, I'd want to give them a chance. You know what I'm saying? Have a little Hollywood.
我还在谈论这件事呢。肯定会有某种影响，对吧？所以，我想给他们一个机会。你明白我的意思吗？来点好莱坞的感觉。
In the beginning, everyone seemed happy to have a little Hollywood. The town got a charming celebrity with bad boy appeal. The celebrity got an adoring public. Richie opened an acting studio, The Richard Castellano School of Acting, and 42 people signed up for his classes. He and his wife also organized the ambitiously named First Annual Narrowsburg International Independent Film Festival. He said Narrowsburg would soon become the Sundance of the East. But, most exciting, he planned to shoot a movie in Narrowsburg, a gangster picture. Richie himself was the lead. People from the town would fill out the cast. 17-year-old Zac Pontier was one of the ones who showed up at the audition.
起初，每个人似乎都很高兴能拥有一点好莱坞的感觉。小镇迎来了一位带有坏小子气质的魅力名人。这位名人得到了一群崇拜他的公众。里奇开了一家表演工作室，叫“理查德·卡斯特拉诺表演学校”，有42人报名参加了他的课程。他和他的妻子还组织了第一届纳罗斯堡国际独立电影节，名字起得雄心勃勃。他说纳罗斯堡很快就会成为东部的圣丹斯（Sundance）。但最让人兴奋的是，他计划在纳罗斯堡拍一部电影，一部黑帮片。里奇本人担任主角，镇上的人将填补其他角色的空缺。17岁的扎克·庞蒂尔（Zac Pontier）就是去参加试镜的人之一。
Well, everybody, and all the kids in the town, and everybody that wanted to be an actor, everybody I knew was there, probably, a huge number of people. And he had people come up and improv scenes. Like, he told you what to say.
嗯，每个人，镇上所有的孩子，所有想成为演员的人，我认识的每个人都在那里，人数非常多。他让人们上台即兴表演场景。比如，他告诉你该说什么。
I remember the scene that he had most people do was this kid, Dominic, was yelling at his sister about how he didn't like his father anymore because he felt like his father killed his mother. So, I was a little nervous when I came up and he said, "Action," or whatever he said. And I just went totally off on this one girl, and I was like, "How dare you talk about our mother like that! She's dead! And if it wasn't for our father, then she'd still be alive! And what about me? What do you think about me? I have nobody!" It went on and on like that.
我记得他让大多数人演的场景是一个叫多米尼克（Dominic）的孩子，他在对他妹妹大喊大叫，说他再也不喜欢他爸爸了，因为他觉得是他爸爸杀了他妈妈。所以我走上去的时候有点紧张，他说“开始”或者别的什么。我完全投入了，对着那个女孩喊道：“你怎么敢那样谈论我们的母亲！她死了！如果不是因为我们的父亲，她现在还活着！那我也算什么？你觉得我是什么？我什么都没有！”诸如此类，一直没停。
So, after it was over, did you feel pretty confident about it?
所以，表演结束后，你对自己有信心吗？
Yeah. He told me I did a good job, and he had me put a star by my name.
有。他告诉我我演得很好，并让我在我的名字旁边画了一颗星。
That had to be a good sign.
那一定是个好兆头。
Yeah, that was. I was like, oh, star, that's a good sign. I'm good to go. And so, I don't know, I remember that we didn't have call waiting then. And so I was like, "Oh, stay off the phone. No one-- Can't talk on the phone." Like, three weeks after that, I talked on the phone very little.
是的，确实是。当时我想，哦，星号，这是个好兆头。我有戏了。所以，我不知道，我记得那时我们还没有呼叫等待功能。所以我告诉自己：“哦，别用电话。没人……不能打电话。”接下来的三周，我基本没怎么打电话。
Eventually, Zac got the part. The movie was called Four Deadly Reasons, and shooting began in the spring of '99. And it was the real deal. Giant Italian characters actors with Brooklyn accents wandered around Main Street. People pushing cameras yelled "Cut," and "Action." Guys in vests hollered into walkie-talkies.
最终，扎克得到了那个角色。这部电影叫《四个致命理由》（Four Deadly Reasons），拍摄于99年春天开始。这可是来真的。带着布鲁克林口音的意大利巨型角色演员在主街上晃荡。推着摄像机的人大喊“咔”和“开始”。穿着背心的家伙们对着对讲机大吼大叫。
Larry Revene, the director of photography, is a 30-year veteran of over 100 low-budget films. He did Hollywood Hot Tubs, Doom Asylum, Bedroom Eyes II . He says, typically, he can shoot a movie in 10 days. The formula always includes either a little T&A, or a little violence.
摄影指导拉里·雷文（Larry Revene）是一位拥有30年经验的老手，拍摄过100多部低成本电影。他拍过《好莱坞热水浴缸》（Hollywood Hot Tubs）、《末日收容所》（Doom Asylum）、《卧室之眼2》（Bedroom Eyes II）。他说，通常情况下，他10天就能拍完一部电影。公式总是包括一点卖肉或者一点暴力。
This [? has no ?] [? pretense ?] to art. This is low-budget, commercial film, you know?
这（？）根本没有任何艺术追求。这就是低成本的商业电影，你懂吗？
Almost immediately, things started going wrong. Castellano was constantly missing from the set. At the end of the first week, the checks he gave the crew all bounced. Stories with headlines like, "Hey, Castellano. Where's My Money?" started appearing in the local paper.
几乎立刻，事情就开始出问题了。卡斯特拉诺总是从片场消失。第一周结束时，他发给剧组的所有支票都跳票了。当地报纸开始出现诸如“嘿，卡斯特拉诺，我的钱在哪里？”之类的标题。
And all sorts of secrets about him came to light. His name wasn't Castellano like the former crime boss, it was Castaldo. He'd never murdered anyone. And the armored car he claimed to have robbed turned out to be a shoe store. It was all playing out like a very old and very familiar story-- charismatic flim-flam man comes to town, raises people's hopes, rips them off, vanishes. "If only it were so simple," says director of photography Larry Revene. "If only Richard were capable of a con like that."
关于他的各种秘密也随之曝光。他根本不是那个犯罪集团头目的那个卡斯特拉诺，他叫卡斯塔尔多（Castaldo）。他从未杀过人。他声称抢劫的那辆装甲车，最后发现其实是一家鞋店。这一切就像一个非常古老且熟悉的故事——魅力十足的骗子进城，吊起人们的胃口，骗光他们的钱，然后消失。摄影指导拉里·雷文说：“如果事情真有那么简单就好了。如果理查德真的有能力策划那样的骗局就好了。”
Well, I think that that would be giving too much credit to him because I don't think he's capable of that kind of thinking ahead. I think he was thinking, you've got some helmets, I've got some swords, let's go to my garage and we'll put on a play. And he's going to believe it too because it's happening. People are involved. It's all going forward. I hope some money shows up, maybe we can pay everybody. And he's playing out his role as this wonderful movie star.
嗯，我觉得那样评价他太高看他了，因为我觉得他根本没能力进行那种预谋。我想他当时想的是，你们有一些头盔，我有一些剑，咱们去我的车库，演一出戏吧。而且他自己也会相信这是真的，因为事情正在发生。人们参与其中，一切都在进行。我希望会有钱出现，也许我们能付给所有人报酬。他正在扮演他作为一名出色电影明星的角色。
17-year-old Zac tells this story. Well into the film, long after the script was done and the parts were cast, Richie was still sending people he'd met to the set, saying that they could get a part in his movie.
17岁的扎克讲述了这样一个故事。电影拍摄期间，在剧本早已完成且角色早已分配完毕很久之后，里奇仍然在向他遇见的每一个人推荐去片场，说他们能在他的电影里得到一个角色。
And this would happen all the time. Every time the town coordinator came outside onto the porch, there would be more people there, like, "Are you the town coordinator? We're looking for the town coordinator. Richie said that we had a big part in his movie. In the scene by the pool, I'm the guy that's supposed to be in it." And the town coordinator would be like, "No, you're not. You're not that guy. I'm sorry. Richie was mistaken."
这种事经常发生。每次镇协调员走到门廊上时，都会有更多的人在那里，就像：“你是镇协调员吗？我们在找镇协调员。里奇说我们在他的电影里有个大角色。在泳池边的那个场景，我就是那个应该出场的人。”而镇协调员会说：“不，你不是。你不是那个人。抱歉，里奇弄错了。”
So they were all standing around like, "Oh, can I have your autograph then?" So I felt really bad for all these people that Richie just-- he didn't get it through his head that, for that time, from when they left where he was and drove to where the movie set, they thought he was the best guy in the world. He wasn't the person that said that they weren't going to be in the movie, he was the person that said they were. So it made him look like a really good guy, a really nice guy. I think that's why he did it. He liked people to think he was a really good guy.
所以他们都站在那儿说：“哦，那我可以要你的签名吗？”所以我为所有这些人感到很难过，里奇只是——他没意识到，在那段时间里，从他们离开他所在的地方开车到电影片场时，他们都以为自己是世界上最棒的人。并不是那个告诉他们无法出演的人让他看起来很糟糕，而是那个说他们能出演的人。所以这让他看起来像个非常好的人，一个非常棒的人。我想这就是他这么做的原因。他喜欢让别人觉得他是个很好的人。
Richie had misled people about who he was. He'd made promises he couldn't keep. But when you talk to him, you get the sense that he'd hooked himself along with everyone else.
里奇误导了人们关于他是谁的信息。他许下了无法兑现的承诺。但当你和他交谈时，你会觉得他不仅骗了别人，连他自己也被骗了进去。
I'd become what I put in my head, and I'd become that person. Like, my wife was just talking. We were watching a movie about Vietnam. And we're sitting there, and I said to my wife, "Yeah, you see that guy, he's in the foxhole? When I was in Vietnam, that's where I used to hide. And when it used to rain, we used to go there." She says, "You were never in Vietnam." I said, "I know," I said, "but it sounds good, don't it?" I find it very easy to do, to become somebody else, because sometimes, if I'm not happy with who I am, I could step into that character.
我成了我脑子里塑造的那个人，我就成了那个人。比如，我妻子刚才在谈话。我们正在看一部关于越南的电影。我们坐在那儿，我对我妻子说：“是啊，看到那个家伙了吗，他在掩体里？我以前在越南时，那就是我躲藏的地方。每当下雨时，我们就去那儿。”她说：“你从没去过越南。”我说：“我知道，”我说，“但听起来不错，对吧？”我发现成为别人非常容易，因为有时候，如果我不喜欢现在的自己，我就能走进那个角色里。
During one of Richie's many appearances in court, the prosecuting attorney asked him if he'd ever told anyone he'd committed murder. He said yes, he had. The attorney then asked if this was true, and he said no. He explained, "I live the roles I play in my movies."
在里奇多次出庭期间，检察官问他是否曾告诉任何人他犯过谋杀罪。他说是的，他确实说过。律师随后问这是否属实，他说没有。他解释说：“我活在我在电影中扮演的角色里。”
The final straw came in August of 2000. For months, advertisements had announced that Four Deadly Reasons would premiere during the Second Annual Narrowsburg Film Festival. Zac Pontier rented a suit especially for the occasion, set up a video camera in the back of the theater to capture the whole event. Here's what he recorded. Joe Dinki, the screenwriter on the film, came out in front of the curtain, sat on the edge of the stage, dangled his legs over the side and, leaning back on one elbow, the microphone in his free hand, delivered this news.
最后一根稻草出现在2000年8月。几个月来，广告一直宣称《四个致命理由》将在第二届纳罗斯堡电影节期间首映。扎克·庞蒂尔为了这个场合专门租了一套西装，还在剧院后排架设了一台摄像机记录整个过程。以下是他录下的内容。电影编剧乔·丁基（Joe Dinki）走到幕布前，坐在舞台边缘，双腿悬空，一只手撑着手肘，另一只手拿着麦克风，传达了这一消息。
Everybody raise their hand, anyone remember those summers where everything just stinks? I wrote this screenplay for Four Deadly Reasons from an original story by Richard's son and another person. And we took it and we made it into a, I think, a very viable, very sellable, very fun, mob film. So let's all applaud Narrowsburg for their participation. Thank you.
大家都举起手来，有人记得那些一切都很糟糕的夏天吗？我根据理查德的儿子和另外一个人的原创故事，编写了《四个致命理由》的剧本。我们把它拿来，拍成了一部我认为非常可行、非常有卖点、非常有趣的黑帮片。所以让我们为纳罗斯堡的参与鼓掌。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
All right!
太好了！
Now, the hard part. We don't have the whole film here today. And I really do apologize. But, what you will see is 15 minutes, sorry, of the film that shows exactly what we were doing, and how much fun it is, and how great your area looks, and all the people that were in this film. So, I don't want to belabor the point and keep apologizing because you guys are great, and I think it's a fun film. And I know it's going to go places. And I'm having one of those really bad summers.
现在，困难的部分来了。我们今天没能带来整部电影。我真的非常抱歉。但是，你们将看到15分钟——抱歉——这部电影的片段，它展示了我们正在做的东西，它有多有趣，你们的地区看起来有多棒，以及所有参与这部电影的人。所以，我不想纠结于这个问题，也不想一直道歉，因为你们都很棒，我认为这是一部有趣的电影。我知道它会取得成功的。而且我正经历着一个糟糕透顶的夏天。
What came next was a hastily produced, 15-minute montage of scenes from the movie. It was like a porn film without the sex scenes-- awkward dialogue, noodly soundtrack, gratuitous use of bikinis and double entendres, and, most offensive, no scenes with people from Narrowsburg. Laurie Stuart, who works at the local paper, said that when it ended, the audience was stunned.
接下来是一个仓促制作的15分钟电影片段剪辑。就像一部没有性爱场景的色情片——尴尬的对话、无聊的配乐、无缘无故出现的比基尼和双关语，最令人反感的是，里面没有任何纳罗斯堡当地人的镜头。在当地报纸工作的劳里·斯图尔特（Laurie Stuart）说，当片段结束时，观众们惊呆了。
You just couldn't believe it. Nobody could believe it. And then, 175 people just were excused, I mean, literally, excused. The guy stood in front of the audience and said, "OK, that's it. You're excused." And 175 people, in disbelief, filed out of that theater. I mean, at that point, any good will that folks had was really just frittered away.
你简直不敢相信。没人敢相信。然后，175个人就这样被“请”出去了，我是说，真的就是被请出去了。那个家伙站在观众面前说：“好的，就这样。请离开。”175个处于难以置信中的人，鱼贯走出了那家剧院。我的意思是，那一刻，大家之前的所有好感真的都被挥霍殆尽了。
After the premiere, people in town stopped treating Richie as a lovably outsized character and set their sights on revenge. Suddenly, everyone was suing him-- a rental car company, 14 people from his film crew, a half dozen of his acting students. Part of the reason they were upset has to do with the real reasons most of them got involved with Richie in the first place. And to understand those reasons, you have to visit someone like John Borg, the biggest investor in Castellano's film.
首映后，镇上的人不再把里奇当作一个可爱但夸张的角色，而是把目光投向了报复。突然间，每个人都在起诉他——一家租车公司，14名剧组成员，半打表演班的学生。他们感到愤怒的部分原因，与他们当初参与里奇电影的真正原因有关。要理解这些原因，你必须去拜访像约翰·博格（John Borg）这样的人，他是卡斯特拉诺电影最大的投资人。
There is all my proceeds from my check, which I give him-- checks, $3,000 here, on 8/10/99, $5,000, 7/9/99.
这是我给他的支票的所有记录，我给他——支票，这里是3000美元，99年8月10日，5000美元，99年7月9日。
John Borg lives in a double-wide trailer on a small farm off a gravel road in the woods. On top of his dresser, there's a handgun laying next to an English pronunciation dictionary. Chickens run free in his yard, and he supplements his social security income by selling their eggs. There's some dispute about just how much money Richard Castellano owes John Borg. Castellano admits to borrowing around $60,000. Borg says it's $154,000. Borg says that, in decades of marriage, he'd never gone out to eat once. He didn't invest in the stock market and, up until he met Castellano, he had his entire life savings in the bank. When I ask him why he loaned so much of his money-- by his account, his entire life savings-- to a man he barely knew, he goes to his living room, picks up a video off the top of the TV, and shows it to me.
约翰·博格住在一辆双宽拖车里，位于树林里的一条碎石路旁的小农场上。他的梳妆台上放着一把手枪，旁边是一本英语发音词典。鸡在院子里自由地跑来跑去，他靠卖鸡蛋来补贴社会保障金。关于理查德·卡斯特拉诺欠约翰·博格多少钱，存在一些争议。卡斯特拉诺承认借了大约6万美元。博格说金额是15.4万美元。博格说，在几十年的婚姻生活中，他从没出去吃过一次饭。他不投资股市，在遇见卡斯特拉诺之前，他把一生的积蓄都存在银行里。当我问他为什么把这么多钱——据他说，是他毕生的积蓄——借给一个他几乎不认识的人时，他走到客厅，从电视机上方拿出一盘录像带给我看。
He said, "I made movie with Robert De Niro and Billy Crystal." I went to buy the movie. I bought it in Kmart in [? Honesdale. ?] I've got the movie right here, Analyze That .
他说：“我和罗伯特·德尼罗和比利·克里斯托拍过电影。”我去买了那部电影。我在霍恩斯代尔（Honesdale）的凯马特（Kmart）买了它。电影就在这儿，《老大靠边闪》。
Did it sound suspicious to you at all, or not really?
你有没有觉得有什么可疑的地方，还是说根本没有？
In the beginning, no, because he's a very great and a very sweet talker. And I believed the guy because of that stupid movie right there.
起初没有，因为他是一个非常棒、非常甜言蜜语的家伙。因为那部该死的电影就在那儿，所以我相信了他。
In the end, one of the most surprising things about this story is just how little stardust Castellano was offering people, a bit role in a so-so Hollywood movie, and how far it took him. John Borg is like most people in Narrowsburg. He says he loaned Richie the money because he thought it would help bring people and business to the area, but you get the sense there's something more. I ask, did Richie ever offer to put him in the movie?
归根结底，这个故事最令人惊讶的事情之一是卡斯特拉诺提供给人们的星光是多么微不足道——一部平庸好莱坞电影里的一个小角色，却让他走得这么远。约翰·博格就像纳罗斯堡的大多数人一样。他说他借钱给里奇是因为他认为这能带动当地的生意和人气，但你会有种感觉，还有别的原因。我问他，里奇有没有提出让他演电影？
"Well," he said, "we're going to see. Maybe going to get you some part." I told him I'm not interested.
“嗯，”他说，“我们到时候看吧。也许能给你安排个角色。”我告诉他我没兴趣。
But part of you was a little interested?
但你内心其实有一点感兴趣，对吧？
Well, if I would be interested, I would have play Marshal Dillon, which I got a picture right there.
嗯，如果我有兴趣的话，我就演马歇尔·迪伦（Marshal Dillon），那张照片就在那儿。
Marshal Dillon, what do you mean?
马歇尔·迪伦，你是什么意思？
At this point, John Borg goes and picks up a framed photograph, resting on a doily on top of his VCR, of a figure with a cowboy hat and a handgun.
此时，约翰·博格走过去，拿起一张放在录像机上花边垫子里的装裱照片，照片上是一个戴着牛仔帽、拿着手枪的人物。
So, this is--
所以，这是——
Yeah, that's me. Yes.
是啊，那是我。是的。
That's you?
那是你？
Yeah. And that's my gun too.
是的。那也是我的枪。
Uh-huh, and you've got a cowboy hat. Is that at your house?
嗯哼，你还有顶牛仔帽。这是在你家吗？
I got my hat here in the closet.
我的帽子在壁橱里。
Yeah. This is the part you wanted to play? Wait, wait.
是啊。这是你想扮演的角色吗？等一下，等一下。
Not much, you know, because we didn't talk too much about it. But he told me that he going to give me a guy going to be like a law enforcement officer. So it was Marshal Dillon. Well, everything [? ran  up for the end, ?] so what can I do?
没多少，你知道，因为我们没聊太多。但他告诉我，他要给我一个角色，就像执法官那样。所以就是马歇尔·迪伦。嗯，一切都（？到最后），那我能做什么呢？
The more time I spend in Borg's house, the more evidence I discover of his obsession with the movies. He owns dozens of videos in big shopping bags, and on shelves, and stacked on tables. Later in the conversation, fairly abruptly in the middle of a story, he gets up, grabs his cowboy hat, turns the brim up like Soupy Sales and announces that he can act, if that's what you call this.
我在博格家里待的时间越长，我就越发现他痴迷电影的证据。他有几十盘录像带装在大购物袋里、架子上，堆在桌子上。在谈话的后期，他在讲故事讲到一半时，突然起身，抓起牛仔帽，把帽檐翻起来，学着苏皮·塞尔斯（Soupy Sales）的样子宣布，如果这就是所谓表演的话，那他也能演。
I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE] guy, and I [UNINTELLIGIBLE] for anybody who [UNINTELLIGIBLE] this.
我是个[乱码]家伙，我[乱码]给任何[乱码]这个的人。
Borg calls this his stupid voice. And, as near as I can figure out, it's a schtick he developed several decades ago in Brooklyn that he used to entertain his co-workers during long night shifts. He says he showed it to Castellano, who said he'd put him in the show.
博格把这称为他的“蠢嗓子”。据我所知，这是他几十年前在布鲁克林开发的一种把戏，用来在长夜班期间取悦同事。他说他把这个表演给卡斯特拉诺看，卡斯特拉诺说会让他上镜。
That's what he said, he's going to put me in the show. "I'm going to give you a wonderful part in the movie." And I don't get [BLEEP], not even one minute. He promised me he's going to put me in a movie, and everything else, but he never have.
他是这么说的，他要让我上镜。“我要给你电影里一个很棒的角色。”但我连[消音]都没得到，一分钟都没有。他承诺让我演电影，还有别的什么，但他从来没兑现过。
You want to know why Paul Vitti comes here? Paul Vitti comes here because his father was whacked here. His father was whacked here? What do you mean he was whacked? Yeah, his father was whacked right here in that corner many years ago.
你想知道为什么保罗·维蒂（Paul Vitti）来这儿吗？保罗·维蒂来这儿是因为他父亲是在这儿被干掉的。他父亲是在这儿被干掉的？你什么意思，被干掉？是啊，他父亲多年前就在那个角落被干掉的。
This is Richard Castellano quoting other people's lines from the movie in which he played a bit role, Analyze This . In our two-hour interview in his lawyer's office, he was defensive and guarded, until I asked him about his favorite actors and favorite movie scenes. He stood up, rubbed his hands together, and got into character.
这是理查德·卡斯特拉诺在引用他客串的那部电影《老大靠边闪》中别人的台词。在我们律师办公室的两个小时采访中，他一直处于防备和戒备状态，直到我问起他最喜欢的演员和电影场景。他站起来，双手搓在一起，进入了角色。
Shut up, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] [? you ?] [? know. ?] Why? What's the big secret, Charlie? Gee, everybody knows what happened to Paul Vitti's father.
闭嘴，[乱码][？你？][？知道吗？]。为什么？有什么大秘密吗，查理？天哪，谁不知道保罗·维蒂父亲身上发生了什么。
Standing there in the conference room, Castellano blocked me into the scene, positioning me a couple of feet from him.
站在会议室里，卡斯特拉诺把我带入了戏中，把我定位在他几英尺外。
You're the doctor.
你是医生。
OK.
好的。
You're the doctor.
你是医生。
Oh, wait. OK, he comes to me. I got you. OK.
哦，等等。好的，他来找我。我知道了。好的。
You know me?
你认识我吗？
Yeah.
知道。
No, you don't. Did you read about me in the paper?
不，你不认识。你在报纸上读到过我吗？
Yeah.
知道。
No, you didn't. See, I was doing Billy Crystal.
不，你没有。看，我是在模仿比利·克里斯托。
Do you know me? No, you don't.
你认识我吗？不，你不认识。
OK.
好的。
You see my picture in the paper?
你在报纸上看到我的照片了吗？
Yes.
是。
No, you didn't.
不，你没有。
I don't even get the paper.
我甚至都不看报纸。
Did you read about me? Oh yes I did. No, you didn't. Well, I didn't even get the paper today. You know, that's Billy Crystal.
你在报纸上读到过我吗？哦，是的，我读过。不，你没有。嗯，我今天甚至都没拿到报纸。你知道，那是比利·克里斯托。
Castellano acted out whole stretches of dialogue from scenes in which he didn't even appear, like someone who'd watched the film dozens of times. It wasn't hard for him to package the dream of Hollywood to the people of Narrowsburg. It was a dream he understood.
卡斯特拉诺演出了整段整段他甚至没有出场的电影对话，就像一个把电影看了几十遍的人。对他来说，向纳罗斯堡的人兜售好莱坞梦想并不难。这是一个他自己也深陷其中的梦想。
Well, I know the feeling it gave me, that I'd go to sleep every night still thinking, did I really act with De Niro in that? I mean, you read, hear so much about big celebrity, the guy that made hundreds of movies. All this talk of the world, he's the best actor in the world. Then here you are, standing right with him, shaking his hand, drinking coffee with him, acting across from him, walking with him and, you know, just being involved with him. It's the most exciting-- the next exciting feeling I'll ever get is when I meet God. That'll be the closest I can get to how I felt when I met Bobby De Niro.
嗯，我知道那种感觉，我每天晚上睡觉时还在想，我真的和德尼罗演过戏吗？我的意思是，你读到、听到那么多关于大明星的消息，那个拍了几百部电影的人。全世界都在谈论他，他是世界上最好的演员。然后你就在这儿，和他站在一起，和他握手，和他喝咖啡，和他演对手戏，和他一起走，你知道，仅仅是参与其中。这是最令人兴奋的……我下一次能得到的最兴奋的感觉就是见到上帝的时候。那将是我能感受到的、最接近我见到鲍比·德尼罗时感觉的东西了。
Everyone I spoke with in Narrowsburg got asked the same question-- if all this were made into a movie, who would you want to play the part of you? And all of them said the same thing, from John Borg, to Zac Pontier, to Richie Castellano. They wanted to play themselves.
我在纳罗斯堡采访的每个人都被问到了同一个问题——如果这一切被拍成电影，你想让谁来演你？他们都说了同样的话，从约翰·博格到扎克·庞蒂尔，再到里奇·卡斯特拉诺。他们都想演自己。
Alex Blumberg is a producer here at This American Life . Four Deadly Reasons was finally released in 2002, and that's two years after this story first was broadcast. It played a few festivals and then went to DVD.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们《美国生活》的制作人。《四个致命理由》最终在2002年上映，那是这个故事首次播出两年后。它在几个电影节上放映过，然后出了DVD。
[MUSIC - "EX-CON" BY SMOG]
[音乐 - SMOG的《前罪犯》]
Coming up, David Sedaris swears he took a bath, really, despite what the tourists say. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来的节目，大卫·塞达里斯发誓他洗过澡了，真的，尽管那些游客们不是这么说的。稍后我们将从国际公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Our show today, The Three Kinds of Deception. Act One, if you'll recall, was about self-deception. We've arrived at Act Two, Deceiving Others.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的相关故事。我们今天的节目主题是“三种欺骗”。如果你们还记得的话，第一幕是关于“自欺欺人”。我们现在来到了第二幕，“欺骗他人”。
When he was 30 years old, a Harvard Law School graduate and a practicing attorney making over $100,000 a year, Lawrence Otis Graham decided to take a job as a busboy at an all-white country club. To be clear, he didn't decide to do this because of his own experience at these kinds of clubs, though he'd had some. Growing up on the border of Scarsdale, New York, there were white families all around that belonged to country clubs, though his family, a well-to-do black family from Memphis, did not.
劳伦斯·奥蒂斯·格雷厄姆（Lawrence Otis Graham）毕业于哈佛大学法学院，是一名年薪超过10万美元的执业律师。30岁时，他决定去一家全白人乡村俱乐部当勤杂工。需要说明的是，他做这个决定并不是因为他自己在这种俱乐部里的经历，尽管他确实有过一些。他在纽约州斯卡斯代尔（Scarsdale）郊区边缘长大，周围有许多白人家庭都属于不同的乡村俱乐部，而他的家庭——一个来自孟菲斯的富裕黑人家庭——却没有。
My very first club experience was not a very positive one. It was when I was around seven years old. My parents objected to my brother and I going to a country club with our best friends who lived across the street. And they belonged to a club that my parents said did not permit blacks or Jews, so they brought us to the club because we insisted we wanted to go. I was seven. My brother was nine.
我第一次去俱乐部的经历并不是很愉快。那是大约我7岁的时候。我的父母反对我和哥哥去街对面的好朋友参加的乡村俱乐部。他们参加的俱乐部，我父母说是不允许黑人或犹太人进入的，但我们坚持要去，所以他们带我们去了。我7岁，我哥哥9岁。
But we got into the children's swimming pool. They had a kiddie pool and then an adult pool. And, within less than two or three minutes, all of the kids got out of the pool. And my brother, Richard, and I ran out of the pool too because we thought there was something in the water that was going to hurt us. And then we realized this was a club that just did not want us there.
但我们进了儿童游泳池。他们有一个浅水池，然后是一个成人泳池。不到两三分钟，所有的孩子都从池子里出来了。我和哥哥理查德也跑出了池子，因为我们以为水里有什么东西会伤害我们。然后我们意识到，这是一个根本不想让我们待在那儿的俱乐部。
My parents had warned me that something might happen, but my brother and I were growing up in what we imagined to be liberal and informed New York suburban communities where we thought that the stories that my parents told us about Memphis and the other parts of the South from the '40s and '50s didn't exist anymore.
父母曾警告过我可能会发生这种事，但我哥哥和我是在我们自以为开明和知情的纽约郊区社区长大的，我们以为父母告诉我们的那些关于40年代和50年代孟菲斯以及南方其他地区的故事已经不复存在了。
I just think about your parents in that situation, of how protective and sad they must have felt for you. But also, at the same time, they must have felt like, well, it's good that you saw it.
我只是在想你的父母在那种情况下，该有多么保护你，又该有多么难过。但与此同时，他们一定觉得，好吧，你能看到这些也是件好事。
Right. They felt it was good that we saw it. They understood the environment. They knew that nothing, physically, would happen to us. But it was an important lesson for me to learn at that age.
对。他们认为让我们看到是件好事。他们了解环境。他们知道我们不会受到身体伤害。但对我那个年龄段的孩子来说，这是一个重要的教训。
Many years later, as an adult working at a fancy Manhattan law firm, Lawrence Otis Graham and his friends all noticed something.
许多年后，作为曼哈顿一家高级律师事务所的成年员工，劳伦斯·奥蒂斯·格雷厄姆和他的朋友们都注意到了某件事。
Many friends who were working in New York, who were black, or Latino, or Jewish, or female, kept sharing stories with me that, in their firms, they were noticing that the people that were moving up had-- in their businesses-- were ones who were brought to country clubs over the weekend. And I started to notice that there was a pattern, that none of us-- none of the blacks, none of the Jews, none of the women, none of the Latinos or Asians-- were being brought.
许多在纽约工作的黑人、拉丁裔、犹太人或女性朋友经常和我分享故事，说在他们的事务所里，他们注意到那些获得晋升的人——在他们的业务中——都是周末被带到乡村俱乐部的人。我开始注意到有一个模式，即我们之中没有一个人——无论是黑人、犹太人、女性、拉丁裔还是亚裔——被邀请过去。
Again, to be clear about his motivations, he wanted to be part of that network. He wanted access to those connections. And he was curious about what, exactly, went on at these exclusive clubs. And that's why he decided to get in the only way that he could, as a busboy.
再次说明，他动机很明确，他想成为那个网络的一部分。他想要获得那些人脉资源。而且他很好奇，这些排外的俱乐部里到底在进行什么活动。这就是他决定通过他唯一能进去的方式——作为一名勤杂工——进去的原因。
For two weeks, he left his high-paid job at the law firm and went undercover, essentially, a black man impersonating a black man. He chose the oldest, most prestigious club he could get to, the 100-year-old Greenwich Country Club, in patrician, white Greenwich, Connecticut. It turned out to be hard work, physically demanding work. And he wrote up this account of his experience.
两周时间里，他离开了律师事务所的高薪工作，实际上是进行了卧底，一个黑人伪装成另一个黑人。他选择了对他来说能进入的最古老、最负盛名的俱乐部，即在贵族气息浓厚的康涅狄格州格林威治，拥有100年历史的格林威治乡村俱乐部。这证明是一项辛苦的工作，对体力要求很高。他写下了这段经历。
March 28 to April 7, 1992. I invented a completely new resume for myself. I erased Harvard, Princeton, and my upper-middle-class suburban childhood from my life. I pieced together a wardrobe with a polyester blazer, ironed blue slacks, black loafers, and a horrendous pink, black, and silver tie, and I set up interviews at clubs.
1992年3月28日至4月7日。我为自己编造了一份全新的简历。我从生活中删除了哈佛、普林斯顿以及我的中上阶层郊区童年。我拼凑了一套行头：一件涤纶西装、烫过的蓝色长裤、黑色平底鞋以及一条恐怖的粉色、黑色加银色领带，然后去俱乐部参加面试。
Over the telephone, five of the eight said that I sounded as if I would make a great waiter. But when they saw that I was black, the club managers told me I would quote, "probably make a much better busboy." "Busboy? Over the phone you said you needed a waiter," I argued.
通过电话，八个面试单位中有五个说我听起来是个理想的服务员人选。但当他们看到我是黑人时，俱乐部经理告诉我，我“可能更适合当一名勤杂工”。“勤杂工？电话里你不是说需要服务员吗？”我争辩道。
Sunday, April 12. Today was my first day at work. Looking in my wallet, I removed my American Express Gold Card, my Harvard Club membership ID, and all of my business cards. When I arrived at the club, my new boss waved me in. "Good morning, Larry," he said with a sufficiently warm smile. "Hi, Mr. Ryan. How's it going?" Glancing at his watch to check my punctuality, he shook my hand and handed me some papers.
4月12日，星期日。今天是我第一天上班。我翻了翻钱包，拿走了我的美国运通金卡、哈佛俱乐部会员证和所有的名片。我到达俱乐部时，我的新老板向我招手。“早上好，拉里（Larry），”他带着一种足够温暖的微笑说道。“嘿，赖安（Ryan）先生。最近怎么样？”他看了一眼手表查看我是否准时，和我握了握手，递给我一些表格。
"Oh, and by the way, where'd you park?" "In front, near the tennis courts." Already shaking his head, he tossed his pencil onto the desk. "That's off-limits to you. You should always park in the back, enter in the back, and leave from the back. No exceptions." "I'll do the forms right now," I said. "And then, I'll be an official busboy." Mr. Ryan threw me an ominous nod. "And Larry, let me stop you now. We don't like that term busboy. We find it demeaning. We prefer to call you busmen." Leading me down the center stairwell to the basement, he added, "And in the future, you will always use the back stairway by the back entrance."
“哦，顺便问一下，你把车停哪儿了？”“在前面，靠近网球场的地方。”他摇了摇头，把铅笔扔到桌子上。“那是禁区。你总是应该停在后面，从后面进入，从后面离开。没有例外。”“我马上填完表格，”我说。“然后，我就正式成为一名勤杂工了。”赖安先生给了我一个不祥的点头。“还有拉里，我得纠正你一下。我们不喜欢‘勤杂工’这个词。我们觉得这有贬低的意思。我们更喜欢叫你们‘巴士男’（Busmen）。”他带我走下中央楼梯来到地下室，补充道：“以后，你要永远使用后门附近的后楼梯。”
He showed me the Mixed Grill, a well-lit pastel room with glass French doors and white wood trim. "Guys, say hello to Larry. He's a new busman at the club." I waved. "And this is Rick, Stephen, Drew, Buddy, and Lee." Five white waiters dressed in white polo shirts with blue 1892 club insignia nodded while busily slicing lemons. "And this is Hector and Carlos, the other busmen." Hector, Carlos, and I were the only non-whites on the serving staff. They greeted me in a mix of English and Spanish. "Nice to meet all of you," I responded. "Thank God," one of the taller waiters cried out. "Finally, somebody who can speak English."
他向我展示了“混合烧烤厅”，一个光线充足、带有法式玻璃门和白色木饰的粉彩房间。“伙计们，跟拉里打个招呼。他是俱乐部新的巴士男。”我挥了挥手。“这是里克（Rick）、斯蒂芬（Stephen）、德鲁（Drew）、巴迪（Buddy）和李（Lee）。”五名穿着白色Polo衫、带有蓝色1892年俱乐部徽章的白人服务员一边忙着切柠檬，一边点头。“这是赫克托（Hector）和卡洛斯（Carlos），另外两名巴士男。”赫克托、卡洛斯和我是在服务人员中仅有的非白人。他们用英语和西班牙语混合着向我打招呼。“很高兴见到你们，”我回应道。“谢天谢地，”其中一名较高的服务员大喊一声。“终于有个会说英语的了。”
Standing outside the ice room, Carlos and I talked about our pasts. He was 25, originally from Colombia, and hadn't finished school. "You going to live in the monkey house?" Carlos asked. "What's that?" We climb the stairs to take our 10-minute lunch break before work begin. "Monkey house is where workers live here," Carlos said.
站在冰库外面，卡洛斯和我谈论了我们的过去。他25岁，来自哥伦比亚，没念完书。“你要住进猴子屋吗？”卡洛斯问。“那是什么？”我们爬上楼梯，在工作开始前进行10分钟的午休。“猴子屋就是这里员工住的地方，”卡洛斯说。
I was soon back downstairs working in the grill. At my first few tables, I tried to avoid making eye contact with members as I removed dirty plates and wiped down tables and chairs. I was sure I'd be recognized. At around 1:15, four men who looked to be in their mid to late 50s sat down at a six-chair table while pulling off their cotton windbreakers and golf sweaters.
我很快又回到楼下在烧烤厅工作。在最初的几桌，我尽量避免与会员进行眼神接触，忙着撤下脏盘子，擦拭桌椅。我肯定会被认出来的。大约1点15分，四个看起来50多岁的人坐在一张有六把椅子的桌旁，脱下了他们的棉质风衣和高尔夫毛衣。
"It's these damned news people that cause all these problems," said golfer number one, shoving his hand deep into a popcorn bowl. "These Negroes wouldn't even be thinking about golf. They can't afford to join a club anyway." Golfer number two squirmed out of his navy blue sweater and nodded in agreement. "My big problem with this Clinton fellow is that he apologized."
“就是这些该死的新闻媒体造成了所有这些问题，”一号高尔夫球手说，把手伸进爆米花碗里。“这些黑鬼（Negroes）甚至不会想到打高尔夫球。反正他们也负担不起加入俱乐部的费用。”二号高尔夫球手挣脱了他的海军蓝毛衣，点头表示同意。“我和这个克林顿家伙的问题是，他道歉了。”
As I stood watching from the corner of the bar, I realized the men were talking about Governor Bill Clinton's recent apology for playing at an all-white golf club in Little Rock, Arkansas. "Hope, I couldn't agree with you more," added golfer number three, a hefty man who was biting off the end of a cigar. "You got any iced tea?" golfer number one asked as I put the silverware and menus around the table. Popcorn flew out of his mouth as he attempted to speak and chew at the same time. "Yes, we certainly do."
当我站在酒吧角落观察时，我意识到这些人在谈论比尔·克林顿州长最近因在阿肯色州小石城一家全白人高尔夫俱乐部打球而作出的道歉。“霍普，我完全同意，”三号高尔夫球手附和道，他是个大块头，正咬着雪茄的末端。“你有冰茶吗？”当我把餐具和菜单摆在桌边时，一号高尔夫球手问道。他边说话边嚼东西，爆米花从嘴里喷了出来。“是的，我们当然有。”
Golfer number three removed a beat-up Rolex from his wrist. "It just sets a bad precedent. Instead of apologizing, he should try to discredit them, undercut them somehow. What's to apologize for?" I cleared my throat and backed away from the table. Suddenly, golfer number one waved me back to his side. "Should we get four iced teas, or just a pitcher and four glasses?" "I'd be happy to bring whatever you'd like, sir."
三号高尔夫球手从手腕上摘下一块破旧的劳力士表。“这开了一个坏先例。他本应该尝试诋毁他们，设法从内部瓦解他们，而不是道歉。有什么可道歉的？”我清了清嗓子，退出了桌边。突然，一号高尔夫球手挥手让我回到他身边。“我们是要四杯冰茶，还是直接来一扎和四个杯子？”“我很乐意为您带来任何您想要的，先生。”
"Oh, busboy," a voice called out as I made the rounds with two pots of coffee. "Here, busboy. Here, busboy," the woman called out. "Busboy, my coffee is cold. Give me a refill." "Certainly. I would be happy to." I reached over for her cup. The 50-ish woman pushed her hand through her straw blond hair and turned to look at me in the face. "Decaf, thank you." "You are quite welcome." Before I turned toward the kitchen, the woman leaned over to her companion. "My goodness, did you hear that? That busboy has diction like an educated white person."
“哦，勤杂工，”当我带着两壶咖啡巡视时，一个声音喊道。“这儿，勤杂工。这儿，勤杂工，”那个女人喊道。“勤杂工，我的咖啡凉了。给我续杯。”“当然，我很高兴为您续杯。”我伸手去拿她的杯子。那个50岁左右的女人撩了一下她那草莓金色的头发，转头看着我的脸。“无咖啡因，谢谢。”“不客气。”在我转向厨房之前，那个女人向她的同伴倾身。“我的天哪，你听到了吗？那个勤杂工说话的语气就像个受过教育的白人。”
A curly-haired waiter walked up to me in the kitchen. "Larry, are you living in the monkey house?" "No, but why do they call it that?" "Well, no offense against you, but it got that name since it's the house where the workers have lived at the club and since the workers used to be Negroes or blacks, it was nicknamed the monkey house. And the name just stuck, even though Negroes have now been replaced by Hispanics."
一个卷发服务员在厨房里向我走来。“拉里，你住在猴子屋吗？”“没有，但他们为什么叫它那个名字？”“嗯，不是针对你，但它得名于那是俱乐部员工住的地方，而且因为过去员工往往是黑人（Negroes），所以被称为猴子屋。这个名字就这么留了下来，尽管黑人现在已经被西班牙裔取代了。”
Saturday, April 18. Today, while I was wiping down a table, I heard a member snap his fingers in my direction. I turned to see a group of young men smoking cigars. They seemed to be my age or a couple of years younger. "Hey, do I know you?" the voice asked. As I turned slowly toward the voice, I could hear my own heartbeat. I was sure it was someone I knew. "No," I said, approaching the blond cigar-smoker. "I don't think so." "You must be new. What's your name?" "My name is Larry. I just started a few days ago."
4月18日，星期六。今天，当我擦桌子时，听到一个会员冲我打了个响指。我转过身，看到一群抽雪茄的年轻男子。他们看起来和我同龄或者比我小几岁。“嘿，我认识你吗？”那个声音问。当我慢慢转过身向那个声音时，我能感觉到自己的心跳。我确定是我认识的人。“没有，”我说，走近那个抽雪茄的金发男。“我不这么认为。”“你一定是新来的。你叫什么名字？”“我叫拉里。我几天前刚开始工作。”
The cigar-smoking host grabbed me by the wrist while looking at his guests. "Well, Larry, welcome to the club. I'm Mr. Billings, and this is Mr. Dennis, a friend and new member." "Hello, Mr. Dennis," I heard myself saying to a freckle-faced young man who puffed uncomfortably on his fat roll of tobacco. The first cigar-smoker gestured for me to bend over, as if he were about to share some important confidence. "Now, Larry, here's what I want you to do. Go get us some of those peanuts, and then give my guests and me a fresh ashtray. Can you manage that?"
那个抽雪茄的东道主抓住了我的手腕，同时看着他的客人们。“嗯，拉里，欢迎来到俱乐部。我是比林斯（Billings）先生，这是丹尼斯（Dennis）先生，一位朋友和新会员。”“你好，丹尼斯先生，”我听到自己对一个满脸雀斑的年轻人说，他正不舒服地吸着那根粗大的烟卷。第一个抽雪茄的人示意我弯下腰，好像要分享什么重要的秘密。“好了，拉里，这就是我要你做的。去给我们拿些花生，然后给我的客人们和我换个干净的烟灰缸。你能办到吗？”
Tuesday, April 21. Just as we were all leaving for the day, Mr. Ryan came down to hand out the new policies for those who were going to be living in the monkey house. Since it had recently been renovated, the club was requiring all new residents to sign the form. The policy included a rule that forbade employees to have overnight guests. Rule 14 stated that the club management had the right to enter an employee's locked bedroom at any time, without permission, and without giving notice.
4月21日，星期二。就在我们所有人要下班离开时，赖安先生下来分发给那些要住进猴子屋的人的新政策。由于刚刚装修过，俱乐部要求所有新住户签署表格。政策包括一条禁止员工有留宿客人的规定。第14条规定，俱乐部管理层有权在未经许可、无需通知的情况下，随时进入员工上锁的卧室。
As I was making rounds with my coffee pots, I overheard a raspy-voiced woman talking to a mother and daughter who were thumbing through a catalog of infants' clothing. "The problem with au pairs is that they're usually only in the country for a year." The mother and daughter nodded in agreement. "But getting one that's a citizen has its own problems. For example, if you ever have to choose between a Negro and one of these Spanish people, always go for the Negro." One of the women frowned, confused. "Really?" "Yes," the raspy-voiced woman responded with cold logic. "Even though you can't trust either one, at least Negroes speak English and can follow your directions." Before I could refill the final cup, the raspy-voiced woman looked up at me and smiled. "Oh, thanks for the refill, Larry."
当我带着咖啡壶巡视时，我无意中听到一个声音沙哑的女人正在和一个正在翻看婴儿服装目录的母女谈话。“互惠生的难题在于她们通常只在这个国家待一年。”母女俩点头表示同意。“但找个公民互惠生也有自己的麻烦。例如，如果你必须在黑人和这些西班牙人之间做选择，一定要选黑人。”其中一个女人困惑地皱起眉头。“真的吗？”“是的，”那个声音沙哑的女人以一种冰冷的逻辑回应。“虽然两者都不可信，但至少黑人会说英语，而且能听从你的指令。”在我还没来得及给最后一个杯子续完咖啡之前，那个声音沙哑的女人抬头看了看我，微笑着说：“哦，谢谢你的续杯，拉里。”
Wednesday, April 22. Today, the TV was turned to testimony and closing arguments from the Rodney King police beating trial in California. "I am so sick of seeing that awful videotape," one woman said to friends at her table. "It shouldn't be on TV."
4月22日，星期三。今天，电视机正放着加利福尼亚罗德尼·金（Rodney King）警察殴打案的证词和结案陈词。“我真看够了那段可怕的录像带，”一个女人对桌边的朋友说。“那根本就不该在电视上播放。”
At around 2:00, Lois, the club's official secretary, asked me to help her send out a mailing to 600 members after my shift. She took me up to her office on the main floor and introduced me to the two women who sat with her. "Larry, this is Marge, whom you'll talk with in three months because she's in charge of employee benefits." I smiled at the brunette. "And, Larry, this is Sandy, whom you'll talk with after you become a member at the club because she's in charge of members' accounts." Both Sandy and I looked up at Lois with shocked expressions. Lois winked and, at the same moment, the three jovial women burst out laughing.
大约2点左右，俱乐部的官方秘书洛伊斯（Lois）让我下班后帮她发送一份给600名会员的邮件。她把我带到她主楼的办公室，向我介绍了和她坐在一起的两个女人。“拉里，这是玛吉（Marge），你三个月后会和她谈，因为她负责员工福利。”我对着那个黑发女子笑了笑。“还有，拉里，这是桑迪（Sandy），你成为俱乐部会员后会和她谈，因为她负责会员账户。”桑迪和我看着洛伊斯，脸上露出了震惊的表情。洛伊斯眨了眨眼，与此同时，这三个开朗的女人爆发出大笑。
Thursday, April 22. At the end of the day, Mr. Ryan handed me my first paycheck. When I opened the envelope and saw what I'd earned, $174.04 for five days, I laughed out loud. Back in the security of a bathroom stall, where I had periodically been taking notes since my arrival, I studied the check and thought about how many hours and how hard I'd worked for so little money. It was less than 1/10 of what I'd make in the same time in my law firm.
4月22日，星期四。下班时，赖安先生给了我第一份工资支票。当我打开信封看到我的收入——五天174.04美元——时，我大笑出声。回到卫生间的隔间里，自从我到达这里后，我就一直定期在那里记笔记，我仔细端详了这张支票，想过我为了这么点钱投入了多少时间和多么辛苦的工作。这不到我在律师事务所同样时间内赚取收入的十分之一。
I went upstairs and asked Mr. Ryan about my paycheck. "Well, we decided to give you $7 an hour," he said. I'd never actually been told my hourly rate. "But if the check looks especially big, Larry, that's because you got some extra pay in there for all of your terrific work on Good Friday. And by the way, Larry, don't tell any of the others what you're getting because we're giving you a special deal, and it's really nobody else's business." I nodded and thanked him for his largess. I stuffed some more envelopes, emptied out my locker, and left.
我上楼去询问赖安先生关于我的工资支票的事。“嗯，我们决定给你每小时7美元，”他说。我从没被告知过我的时薪。“但如果支票看起来特别大，拉里，那是因为你在耶稣受难日（Good Friday）的出色工作得到了一些额外报酬。顺便说一句，拉里，不要告诉其他人你拿多少，因为我们给了你一个特殊待遇，而且这真的不关别人的事。”我点了点头，感谢他的慷慨。我装好更多的信封，清空了储物柜，然后离开了。
Lawrence Otis Graham, reading from one of the essays in his book, Member of the Club . He says he wasn't surprised at what he called the passive bigotry of the club members, who, he said, did not think of themselves as racist. Interestingly, the more pointed language came from club staff who routinely used the word nigger.
劳伦斯·奥蒂斯·格雷厄姆，摘自他书中的一篇散文《俱乐部成员》。他说，他对俱乐部成员所谓的被动偏见并不感到惊讶，这些人说，他们并不认为自己是种族主义者。有趣的是，更尖锐的语言来自俱乐部员工，他们经常使用“黑鬼”（nigger）这个词。
It was not a reference to me, but it was in reference to them watching television. The television was constantly on, so it was, there those niggers are again kind of thing. But, two seconds later, they would turn to me and say, "Oh, Larry, can you come, do so-and-so?" I honestly don't even believe that they thought that people would have been offended by the use of the term.
那不是指我，而是指他们在看电视时说的。电视一直开着，所以会说，又有那些黑鬼了。但两秒钟后，他们会转向我说：“哦，拉里，你能过来做下那个谁吗？”我甚至不相信他们认为人们会因为使用这个词而感到冒犯。
When you heard this, were you surprised at all?
当你听到这个时，你感到惊讶吗？
No. No.
不，不。
Not at all?
一点也不？
I'll tell you why I wasn't surprised. I wasn't surprised because of what they had put me through in order to get the job. I had three call-back interviews for this job, three call-back interviews for a busboy job.
我告诉你我为什么不惊讶。我不惊讶是因为他们为了让我得到这份工作而让我经历的事情。我有三次回访面试，为了一个勤杂工的工作，有三次面试。
Wow.
哇。
I mean, that is outrageous. If you look at what it would take to get a job at IBM, I don't think you'd have three call-back jobs. So it was very clear to me there was something about myself that made them feel uncomfortable.
我的意思是，这太离谱了。如果你看看在IBM找份工作需要什么，我觉得你都不需要三次面试。所以很清楚，我身上有什么东西让他们感到不舒服。
We called the Greenwich Country Club to find out if the club now admits blacks, or Jews, or any minority members at all. The club declined to respond.
我们致电格林威治乡村俱乐部询问该俱乐部现在是否接纳黑人、犹太人或任何少数族裔成员。俱乐部拒绝回应。
[MUSIC - "CHEAP LABOR" BY NEO BOYS]
[音乐 - NEO BOYS的《廉价劳动力》]
Act Three, Accidental Deception. OK, to review, thus far on our program we have witnessed self-deception, the willful deception of others, and how one of those can lead to the other.
第三幕，意外的欺骗。好的，总结一下，到目前为止，我们的节目已经见证了自欺欺人、对他人蓄意的欺骗，以及这两者是如何互相转化的。
David Sedaris is a writer living, these days, in Paris, France, with his boyfriend, Hugh. He now has this story of accidental deception and how it can send somebody down the slippery slope to both of the other kinds.
大卫·塞达里斯是一位作家，目前与他的男朋友休（Hugh）住在法国巴黎。他现在有一个关于意外欺骗的故事，以及它是如何把一个人推向通往其他两种欺骗的滑坡的。
It was July, and Hugh and I were taking the Paris Metro from our neighborhood to a store where we hoped to buy a good deal of burlap. During the summer months, a great number of American vacationers can be found riding the Metro, and their voices tend to carry. It's something I hadn't noticed until leaving home, but we are a loud people.
那是七月，休和我在巴黎坐地铁去一家我们希望买到大量粗麻布的商店。夏季月份里，许多美国度假者会乘坐地铁，他们的嗓门通常很大。这是我在离开家之前没注意到的，但我们确实是个吵闹的民族。
On the first of our two trains, I listened to a quartet of college-age Texans who sat beneath a sign instructing passengers to surrender their seats and stand, should the foyer of the train become too crowded. The foyer of the train quickly became too crowded. And, while the others stood to make more room, the young Texans remained seated and raised their voices in order to continue their debate, the topic being which is the better city, Houston or Paris?
在我们搭乘的两趟列车中的第一趟上，我听着四个德克萨斯大学的学生在一块标识下聊天，那个标识指示乘客在列车门厅过于拥挤时让出座位并站立。列车门厅很快变得过于拥挤。而在其他人站起来腾出空间时，那几个年轻的德州学生仍然坐着，提高嗓门继续他们的辩论，主题是休斯顿还是巴黎哪座城市更好？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It was a hot afternoon, and the subject of air conditioning came into play. Houston had it, Paris did not. Houston also had ice cubes, tacos, plenty of free parking, and something called a Sonic burger. Things were not looking good for Paris, which lost valuable points every time the train stopped to accept more passengers.
那是一个炎热的下午，空调的话题随之而来。休斯顿有空调，巴黎没有。休斯顿还有冰块、塔可、充足的免费停车位，以及一种叫“索尼克”（Sonic）的汉堡。巴黎的情况看起来很不妙，列车每停靠一次接受新乘客，巴黎就会扣掉宝贵的分数。
The crowds packed in, surrounding the seated Texans and reducing them to four disembodied voices. From the far corner of the car, one of them shouted that they were tired and dirty and ready to catch the next plane home. The voice was weary and hopeless, and I identified completely. It was the same way I'd felt on my last visit to Houston.
拥挤的人群包围了坐着的德州人，把他们缩减成四个没身体的声音。在车厢的最角落，其中一个人喊道，他们很累，很脏，准备搭下一班飞机回家了。声音充满了疲惫和绝望，我完全感同身受。和我上次去休斯顿时的感觉一模一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hugh and I disembarked to the strains of "Texas, Our Texas," and boarded our second train, where an American couple in their late 40s stood hugging the floor-to-ceiling support pole. There's no sign saying so, but such poles are not considered private. They're put there for everyone's use. You don't treat it like a fireman's pole. Rather, you grasp it with one hand and stand back at a respectable distance. It's not all that difficult to figure out, even if you come from a town without any public transportation.
休和我伴随着《德克萨斯，我们的德克萨斯》的歌声下车，登上了第二趟列车，一对40岁出头的美国夫妇正紧抱着那根从地板到天花板的支撑杆。没有标识说，但这种杆子不被认为是私人的。它们是供所有人使用的。你不要把它当成消防员的杆子。相反，你应该一只手握住它，站在保持礼貌距离的地方。这并不难弄明白，即使你来自一个没有任何公共交通的城镇。
The train left the station and, needing something to hold onto, I wedged my hand between the American couple and grabbed the pole at waist level. The man then turned to the women saying, "PU, can you smell that? That is pure French, baby."
列车离开车站，因为需要抓住什么东西保持平衡，我把手插在那对美国夫妇中间，抓住了腰部的杆子。那个男人转过身对女人说：“PU（臭死了），你闻到了吗？那可是纯粹的法国味儿，宝贝。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He removed one of his hands from the pole and waved it back and forth in front of his face. "Yes, indeed," he said, "this little froggie is ripe." It took a moment to realize he was talking about me. The woman wrinkled her nose. "Golly, Pete," she said, "do they all smell this bad?" "It's pretty typical," the man said. "I'm willing to bet that our little friend here hasn't had a bath in a good two weeks. I mean, Jesus Christ, someone should hang a deodorizer around this guy's neck." The woman laughed, saying, "You crack me up, Martin. I swear, you do."
他把一只手从杆子上移开，在脸前扇了扇。“没错，”他说，“这只小青蛙（little froggie）真够臭的。”我花了一会儿才意识到他是在说我。那个女人皱了皱鼻子。“天哪，皮特，”她说，“他们都这么臭吗？”“很正常，”男人说。“我敢打赌我们这个小哥儿们两周没洗过澡了。我的意思是，天哪，真应该在他脖子上挂个除臭剂。”那个女人笑着说：“你真逗，马丁。我发誓，你真幽默。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's a common mistake for vacationing Americans to assume that everyone around them is French and, therefore, speaks no English whatsoever. An experienced traveler could've told by looking at my shoes that I wasn't French. And, even if I were French, it's not as if English is some mysterious tribal dialect spoken only by anthropologists and a small population of cannibals. Because they had used the tiresome word froggie and complained about my odor, I was now licensed to hate this couple as much as I wanted. This made me happy, as I'd wanted to hate them from the moment I'd entered the subway car.
度假的美国人通常会有一个共同的错误假设，即周围的每个人都是法国人，因此根本不会说英语。一个有经验的旅行者看一眼我的鞋子就能知道我不是法国人。而且，即使我是法国人，英语也不是什么只有人类学家和少数食人族才会说的神秘部落方言。因为他们使用了“青蛙”这个讨厌的词，还抱怨我的气味，所以我现在有理由尽情讨厌这对夫妇了。这让我很开心，因为从我进入车厢的那一刻起，我就想讨厌他们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Unleashed by their insults, I was now free to criticize Martin's clothing-- the pleated denim shorts, the baseball cap, the t-shirt advertising a San Diego pizza restaurant. Glasses hung from his neck on a fluorescent cable, and the couple's bright, new, his-and-hers sneakers suggested that they might be headed somewhere dressy for dinner.
在他们侮辱的刺激下，我现在可以自由地批评马丁的穿着了——褶皱牛仔短裤、棒球帽、印着圣地亚哥披萨店广告的T恤。眼镜挂在他脖子上的一根荧光绳上，那对夫妇崭新的、情侣款的运动鞋暗示着他们可能正打算去什么正式的地方吃晚餐。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Comfort has its place, but it seems rude to visit another country dressed as if you've come to mow its lawns.
舒适感固然重要，但打扮得像去割草一样去另一个国家旅行似乎不太礼貌。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
People are often frightened of Parisians, but an American in Paris will find no harsher critic than another American. France isn't even my country, but there I was, deciding that these people needed to be sent back home, preferably in chains. In disliking them, I was forced to recognize my own pretension, and that made me hate them even more.
人们通常害怕巴黎人，但美国人在巴黎找不到比另一个美国人更严厉的批评者了。法国甚至不是我的国家，但我却在那里决定这些人需要被送回家，最好是带着镣铐。在讨厌他们的过程中，我被迫认清了自己的自命不凡，这让我更加讨厌他们了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The train took a curve and, when I moved my hand further up the pole, the man turned to the woman, saying, "Carol. Hey, Carol, watch out. That guy's going after your wallet." "What?" "Your wallet," Martin said, "that joker's trying to steal your wallet. Move your pocketbook to the front where he can't get at it." She froze. And he repeated himself, barking, "The front! Move your pocketbook around to the front! Do it now! The guy's a pickpocket!"
列车转弯时，当我的手向上移到杆子上时，男人转向女人说：“卡罗尔（Carol）。嘿，卡罗尔，小心。那家伙要偷你的钱包。”“什么？”“你的钱包，”马丁说，“那个小丑正试图偷你的钱包。把你的皮包移到前面去，他够不到的地方。”她僵住了。他重复了一遍，咆哮道：“前面！把你的包移到前面来！现在就做！那家伙是个扒手！”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The woman named Carol grabbed for the strap on her shoulder and moved her pocketbook so that it now rested upon her stomach. "Wow," she said. "I sure didn't see that coming." "Well, you've never been to Paris before, but let that be a lesson to you." Martin glared at me. His eyes narrowed to slits. "This city is full of stinkpots like our little friend here. Let your guard down and they'll take you for everything you've got." Now I was a stinkpot and a thief.
那个名叫卡罗尔的女人抓住肩带，把皮包移到肚子前。“哇，”她说。“我确实没料到会有这出。”“好吧，你以前没来过巴黎，但让这成为给你的一个教训。”马丁盯着我，眼睛眯成一条缝。“这个城市充满了像我们这个小哥儿们这样的臭东西。一旦放下戒备，他们就会骗走你所有的东西。”现在我成了“臭东西”和“小偷”。
It occurred to me to say something, but I thought it might be better to wait and see what he came up with next. Besides, if I said something at this point, he probably would have apologized and I wasn't interested in that. His embarrassment would have pleased me, but once he recovered, there would be that awkward period that sometimes culminates in a handshake. I didn't want to touch these people's hands or see things from their point of view. I just wanted to continue hating them, and so I kept my mouth shut and stared off into space.
我本想说点什么，但我觉得最好等等看他接下来会出什么招。再说，如果我现在开口，他可能会道歉，而我对此不感兴趣。他的尴尬会让我感到愉悦，但一旦他恢复过来，就会出现那种尴尬的停顿，有时甚至以握手告终。我不想触碰这些人的手，也不想从他们的角度看问题。我只想继续讨厌他们，所以我闭上嘴，两眼空洞地望着虚空。
The train stopped at the next station. Passengers got off. And Carol and Martin moved to occupy two folding seats located beside the door. I thought they might ease onto another topic, but Martin was on a roll now, and there was no stopping him. "It was some [BLEEP] head like him that stole my wallet on my last trip to Paris," he said, nodding his head in my direction. "He got me on the subway, came up from behind, and I never felt a thing. Cash, credit cards, driver's license, poof, all of it gone, just like that." I pictured a scoreboard reading Marty, zero; stinkpots, one.
列车在下一站停下。乘客下了车。卡罗尔和马丁移到门边的两个折叠椅上坐下。我原以为他们会换个话题，但马丁现在兴致正高，根本停不下来。“上次去巴黎时，就是某个像他一样的[消音]头偷了我的钱包，”他点头示意我这边。“他在地铁上抓住了我，从背后接近，我一点感觉都没有。现金、信用卡、驾照，砰，全没了，就像那样。”我脑海里出现了一个比分牌：马蒂，零；臭东西，一。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"What you've got to understand is that these creeps are practiced professionals," he said. "I mean, they've really got it down to an art, if you can call that an art form." "I wouldn't call it an art form," Carol said. "Art is beautiful, but taking people's wallets, that stinks, in my opinion." "You've got that right," Martin said. "The thing is that these jokers usually work in pairs." He squinted toward the opposite end of the car. "Odds are that he's probably got a partner somewhere on this subway car." "You think so?" "I know so," he said. "They usually time it so that one of them clips your wallet just as the train pulls into the station. The other guy's job is to run interference and trip you up once you catch wind of what's going on. Then the train stops, the doors open, and they disappear into the crowd. If stinky there had gotten his way, he'd probably be halfway to Timbuktu by now. I mean, make no mistake, these guys are fast."
“你必须明白的是，这些混蛋是经验丰富的职业选手，”他说。“我是说，他们真的把这变成了一门艺术，如果那也能叫艺术的话。”“我不称之为艺术，”卡罗尔说。“艺术是美的，但偷别人的钱包，在我看来简直臭不可闻。”“你说得对，”马丁说。“关键是，这些小丑通常是搭档行事的。”他斜着眼向车厢的另一端看去。“可能性很大，他在这辆地铁上还有个同伙。”“你这么认为？”“我敢肯定，”他说。“他们通常算好时间，在列车进站的一瞬间下手。另一个人的工作是负责阻挠和绊住你，一旦你意识到发生了什么事。然后列车停下，门打开，他们就消失在人群中。如果‘臭东西’得逞的话，他现在可能已经在去廷巴克图（Timbuktu）的路上了。我的意思是，别搞错了，这些家伙动作很快。”
I'm not the sort of person normally mistaken for being fast and well-coordinated, and, because of this, I found Martin's assumption to be oddly flattering. "It just gets my goat," he said. "I mean, where's the polizioni when you need one?" Polizioni? Where did he think he was? I tried to imagine Martin's conversation with a French policeman, and pictured him waving his arms shouting, "That man tried to pick-a my friend's pocketoni!" I wanted very much to hear such a conversation, and so I decided I would take the wallet from Hugh's back pocket as we left the train.
我通常不是那种会被误认为动作迅速、协调性好的人，正因为如此，我发现马丁的臆测竟然有点让人受宠若惊。“这简直让我火大，”他说。“我的意思是，需要警察的时候他们在哪里？”警察（Polizioni）？他以为他在哪儿？我试图想象马丁与法国警察的对话，幻想着他挥舞着手臂喊道：“那个人试图偷我朋友的口袋（pocketoni）！”我非常想听到这样的对话，所以我决定在离开列车时从休的后口袋里拿走钱包。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Martin would watch me steal from a supposed stranger and would most likely intercede. He'd put me in a headlock or yell for help. And, when a crowd gathered, I'd say, "What's the problem? Is it against the law to borrow money from my own boyfriend?" If the police came, he would explain the situation in his perfect French while I'd toss in a few of my most polished phrases. "That guy's crazy," I'd say, pointing at Martin. "I think he's drunk. Look at how his face is swollen."
马丁会看着我偷一个所谓的陌生人，很可能会干预。他会给我来个锁喉或者大声求救。然后，当人群聚集时，我会说：“有什么问题吗？向我自己的男朋友借钱也犯法吗？”如果警察来了，他会用他那完美的法语解释情况，而我会插进几句我最精炼的词组。“那家伙疯了，”我会说，指向马丁。“我觉得他喝醉了。看他脸肿的。”
I was practicing these lines to myself when Hugh came up from behind and tapped me on the shoulder, signaling that the next stop was ours. "There you go," Martin said. "That's him. That's the partner. Didn't I tell you he was around here somewhere? They always work in pairs. It's the oldest trick in the book." Hugh had been reading the paper and had no idea what had been going on. It was too late now to pretend to pick his pocket, and I was stuck without a decent backup plan.
我正对着自己练习这些台词时，休从后面走过来拍了拍我的肩膀，示意下一站就是我们要下的。 “看吧，”马丁说。“那就是他。那是同伙。我不是告诉过你他就在附近吗？他们总是搭档行事。这是这行里最古老的伎俩了。”休一直在看报纸，根本不知道发生了什么。现在再假装偷他的钱包已经太晚了，我被困住了，没有了像样的后备计划。
As we pulled into the station, I recalled an afternoon 10 years earlier. I'd been riding the Chicago El with my sister, Amy, who was getting off two or three stops ahead of me. The doors opened. And, as she stepped out of the crowded car, she turned around to yell, "So long, David. Good luck beating that rape charge."
列车进站时，我想起了十年前的一个下午。我和妹妹艾米（Amy）坐着芝加哥的轨道列车，她比我早下两三站。门开了。当她走出拥挤的车厢时，她转过身大喊：“再见，大卫。祝你打赢那场强奸官司好运。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Everyone on board had turned to stare at me. Some seemed curious, some seemed frightened, but the overwhelming majority appeared to hate me with a ferocity I had never before encountered. "That's my sister," I said.
车上所有人都转过头盯着我。有些人显得好奇，有些人显得惊恐，但绝大多数人似乎带着一种我从未遇到过的凶狠态度憎恨我。“那是我妹妹，”我说。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"She likes to joke around." I laughed and smiled, but it did no good. Every gesture made me appear more guilty. And I wound up getting off at the next stop rather than continue riding alongside people who thought of me as a rapist.
“她喜欢开玩笑。”我笑了笑，但这没用。每一个动作都让我看起来更加罪有应得。最后，我不得不在下一站下车，而不是继续与那些认为我是强奸犯的人坐在一起。
I wanted to say something that good to Martin, but I can't think as fast as Amy. In the end, this man would go home warning his friends to watch out for pickpockets in Paris. He'd be the same old Martin, but, at least for the next few seconds, I still had the opportunity to be somebody different, someone quick and dangerous. The new and dangerous me noticed how Martin tightened his fists when the train pulled to a stop. Carol held her pocketbook close against her chest and sucked in her breath as Hugh and I stepped out of the car, no longer finicky little boyfriends on their overseas experiment, but rogues, accomplices, halfway to Timbuktu.
我想对马丁说一些同样精彩的话，但我没法像艾米那样思维敏捷。最终，这个男人会回到家警告他的朋友们在巴黎要当心扒手。他还是那个老马丁，但至少在接下来的几秒钟里，我还有机会成为一个不同的人，一个机敏而危险的人。那个崭新的、危险的我注意到列车进站时马丁是如何握紧拳头的。卡罗尔紧紧抱着皮包压在胸前，屏住呼吸，休和我走出了车厢，不再是海外实验中挑剔的小男友，而是流氓，同伙，已经走在去往廷巴克图的一半路上了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
David Sedaris, reading an excerpt from his book Me Talk Pretty One Day .
大卫·塞达里斯，摘自他书中的片段《讲得漂亮的那一天》（Me Talk Pretty One Day）。
Our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, Starlee Kine, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for this show Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. [? Sho Ja Yung ?] runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and [? Vija ?] [? Navarro. ?]
今天的节目由布鲁·谢维尼（Blue Chevigny）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）、斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）参与制作。本节目的特约编辑为保罗·托夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。[？Sho Ja Yung？]负责维护我们的网站。感谢赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）和[？维加？][？纳瓦罗？]（[？Vija？] [？Navarro？]）提供的制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcasts or listen to our old programs online for absolutely free. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以获取我们免费的每周播客，或者在线免费收听我们过去的节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Torey Malatia, who's all mad at me.
本节目由WBEZ管理层托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）监督，他现在正生我的气呢。
How dare you talk about our mother like that! She's dead! And if it wasn't for our father, then she'd still be alive! And what about me? What do you think about me? I have nobody!
你怎么敢那样谈论我们的母亲！她死了！如果不是因为我们的父亲，她现在还活着！那我也算什么？你觉得我是什么？我什么都没有！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life. Hey, Torey, say something else to the people.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。嘿，托雷，再跟听众们说点什么吧。
I'm going to give you a wonderful part in the movie.
我要给你电影里一个很棒的角色。
Promises.
承诺。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。